what makes a movie marketable
I mean there could be a lot of things
that make it marketable
um I find look
everyone says Stars sell sell films it's
not untrue it definitely helps to have
recognizable faces beloved faces uh uh
that are in your movie
um sometimes you can't afford people
because you're low budget sag ultra low
budget film
um so
uh
genre I think that's something that
helps sell a film you have you know for
horror movies there are I don't know 220
horror conventions a year there's not
220 romantic comedy conventions right so
this audience is a very loyal audience
right they they're seeking this kind of
material out they definitely you know
love physical media so you know you can
sell different
have different revenue streams based off
of like you know whatever kind of movie
you've made it's a genre movie
um they they're loyal they're very loyal
and for some of them they really don't
care what the quality of the film is
necessarily like if it took this gross
out like slash or something rather and
it's like the worst movie ever somebody
loves that movie by the way there's some
horror fan that just beloved is that
movie's beloved to them
um so it doesn't have to necessarily be
the highest quality necessarily
um but like everything else there's
people that are Discerning within the
genre too the people who want some of
like smarter films or like you know
they're they enjoy the a24 type of
movies which are very you know in their
own rights their own kind of brand but
very interesting and thoughtful a lot of
times you know a lot of different things
can go into it like you could have a
movie with no stars but it's just the
most spectacular ballet of violence and
you know action and everything else that
people
you don't need to have any stars in The
Raid you know I mean like the raid part
two was even better than the raid part
one and you don't know any of those
people at least you didn't at the time
right and they became action stars of
sorts but you know
it can it can be just the way that's
presented like it can be so stylistic
that it's just so um interesting
um there's a Russian Film called why
don't you just die which is like one of
the best films this guy is like the air
to Tarantino we met at the film festival
he's a physicist like he's a physicist
but he's made this like amazing ballet
of violence and and just like just
amazing uh the camera work everything
else is just amazing and that Russian
Film that's just like a tour de force of
violence can be marketable just because
it's so stylistic and interesting
looking right just cut a nice trailer
for that that's very marketable it can
come from different places right people
want to see new stuff that they haven't
seen before you know terrifier too going
back to that like it's so Ultra violent
that people are losing their minds over
because they haven't seen something just
violent in a lot of a long time like it
is just beyond like sorry I'm making a
commercial for terrifier too but like
it's but I'm saying it's different it's
so different it's so interesting that
that's someone's don't like marketing
campaign you know hadn't seen this
before you haven't seen this in a long
time
what makes 1vr marketable
um I think there's a lot of
accessibility to it
um I think that like you know who hasn't
moved to a new city and felt very lonely
even though Los Angeles is a sprawling
you know Metropolitan City it's very
easy to feel very lonely here I mean you
know you get in your you go to work you
get in your car you're by yourself in
your car driving home you know you get
home you're just kind of by yourself
it's not like it's New York where you're
on the subway and you just happen to
meet people you know when you go out you
have to drive to go out places you have
to drive to go to the bar you have drive
to go to the movies whatever it's very a
lonely City it can be and I think that's
a sort of universal thing that people
have experienced loneliness in a city
in the in the wanting to belong to some
extent the other thing that was
interestingly marketable about 1br is
when it came out like we came out during
covid it was very meta in the way that
you know we're sitting here during
covert can I trust that neighbor can I
trust that neighbor you don't trust your
neighbors and this movie's coming out
it's only about not trusting your
neighbors to some extent so there was
sort of an interesting angle to that
that just happened to be because of
covid
um but um in terms of the marketing of
it uh look we we worked very hard on the
trailer
um we worked very hard on the poster we
really put them you know through the
ringer we kept on sending it back that
gives away the whole movie do this do
this cut this do this let's change the
voice at the end of the trailer and we
did to throw people off even more right
um the that the we had elements you know
we have a pretty girl who's in Peril and
she's like going through this terrible
experience
um these are kind of you know things
that are very common in the horror space
you know there's the idea of a final
girl the idea of somebody like you know
having to surpass all these obstacles to
to get to this place where they're free
um is is very sort of universal in its
own right too
um but look the main thing was this in
terms of marketing the film we had
trailer moments and we had enough
critical claim they were able to bake
that into there too like all you see a
bunch of like uh different uh quotes
from critics that are coming up uh that
are actually really pointed well one BR
could be a new cult classic one broke
you put things in there like that and it
kind of turns people's heads it gets
them to notice right and also we don't
give away too much in the trailer which
I think is important too people watched
me like oh you didn't give anything away
so that that's uh I hope that answers
the question in terms of uh what's
marketable at the film got a good
trailer we had a barely striking poster
in fact the trailer got nominated for a
golden trailer award it was one of the
only independent films in that category
we lost the Joker so I feel like you
know not only saying that we did a good
job with the trailer like someone else
you know a major you know the importance
thought so too
who came up with the poster for one br
you know it was uh it was our
distributor had a a an artist who
initially came up with like sort of the
idea of him we had a couple different
ideas and then we chose the best one and
then we started like nitpicking at it
um to do different things to like put a
palm tree in there and to like you know
put people on the walkway and like make
them more menacing or did we went with
them back and forth like for a couple
months and went back and forth with them
so yeah it was I mean it's their artist
idea but then we helped uh you know mold
it
while you were making one BR how much
are you thinking about the marketing
um
you know
we were trying to look I think that you
have to sort of see what you have first
frankly we were thinking about you know
different ideas of what to do but we the
initial thought for the whole thing was
that we would have a festival run first
and that we would go to a we would
hopefully get into a major Festival one
of the two I mentioned before Citrus or
uh um Fantasia that has a Marketplace
there
and the idea was to go there and have
people watch like two screens of it and
we know there was a lot of Distributors
that would be there and we were hoping a
bidding war got started and indeed it
did get started there so that was the
plan to First do a festival run uh get
the awareness and hopefully get a
distributor and then it was we knew we'd
have to work with the distributor they
want to feel like you know they're they
know more they would tell you and maybe
they do on certain for certain aspects
for example
um we never cut a trailer before we went
to uh Festival because it's time and
expense for you you probably can't do it
better than the guys that are paid to do
it I can tell you that
and um once it gets into the Google
Sphere or whatever it's hard to pull
that back right that's the first thing
people are going to see from your movie
so if you're going to do something for a
festival for awareness maybe pick a
scene from the movie and you know put
that out there yeah that's probably good
enough
because invariable will happen is the
distributor is going to want to put
going to want to come up with their
trailer their own trailer in fact
because you could maybe put something
great together and be like oh thanks for
the time and expense we're not going to
use that we're going to come up with
something else right so
um that's that's sort of uh you know
what the what the plan was for us we
didn't have a trailer we got to the to
the festival uh we got a bidding war
started we sold the movie uh to we gave
gave the rights to this distributor and
then we proceeded to
um finish up the festival world tour at
the same time working on the trailer and
the poster with a distributor but you
have some bumpy starts because you
didn't have it finished but you sent it
to 17. yes they they I mean basically
the the year uh the let's say our fall
of 2018 when we had just finished the
reshoots we tried to quickly put the
things in that into the the cut we had
and then send that off and so basically
from like September of 2018 until I want
to say almost May of 2019
um we had been rejected all over the
place but we were testing it and
actually still cutting it down and
making it Tighter and Tighter and uh in
terms of helping um the testing helped
us with that quite a lot and it actually
helped us decide on which ending we
actually shot multiple endings we did
reshoots
um so it helped us figure out which
ending we were going to go with it
helped us figure out
um you know
little minute things like how much cat
violin should we have in it for example
should we have less should we should
more or should we do you know the answer
was less
um uh but all these things helped Titan
film get into shape but finally in in um
excuse me may we were um accepted by um
Fantasia and at that point we were like
okay now we have our work cut out for us
let's go to these other festivals and
see what we can do and from basically
when we premiered in July of 2019 we
were
pretty much like going all over the
world till literally January of 2020
right when covid was starting to hit
like we finished our last Festival in in
France like in the Alps or something and
came home and we're just like I'm
surprised I don't have covet
so having Fantasia say yes to you is
kind of like the popular girl saying yes
to go to the dance and then now you're
now you're invited all the parties 100
it's like just that just that she's all
that analogy
um yeah like I took my glasses off and
all of a sudden I did this and all of a
sudden you know yeah essentially that's
what it is it's it's you get
you get validated by like a a real
um taste maker like Fantasia and all of
a sudden everyone's like wait wait what
okay yeah okay uh I'll take a look yeah
no problem and people came to us too
like it wasn't just us like having to go
out and you know you know pound the
pavement and whatever else people
started approaching us and we're like oh
my gosh I'd love to put you program you
and like okay that's great you were on
our list
what changes would you make to the
marketing if you had to do it all over
again for one VR
or maybe you wouldn't maybe you did
everything I mean look in the context of
what we were living through in terms of
covet and stuff I really wouldn't have
changed anything I mean who's to say
that it would have even done as much
marketing for it if there hadn't been
coveted because frankly we probably
would have been on to the next thing I
mean we were just like oh this is
successful let's take the success of
this and try to roll it into the next
project we're making
if anything that probably hurt us who
would hurt us in that regard because
like all this heat you're having during
covet is including necessarily
remembered over here I mean it is to
some extent but who knows like when
you're the hot thing it's better to try
to strike get a deal or some some sort
and get some funding for the next one or
whatever at the same time
um but I don't know that
um
I mean there's two interesting things
going on with this film one you have
somebody who knows about marketing the
film two you have someone with nothing
to do like during covet not a lot to do
let's say three you have someone
invested money in the movie so anything
we do is a direct you know it's directly
going to get our money back for us let's
say right so there is a real reason to
try to work at it every day right so
this is an interesting sort of thing
that happened because of the situation
we were in covid
um going to question would I do anything
different in terms of marketing I don't
know that I would I feel like if
anything people should do more of what
we did to try to do their films if they
they really think that they have here's
the thing if you don't have something
like we tested the film right remember I
talked to the scores excellent very good
good Fair poor right we'd score very
good
we'd also score for the deathly
recommend score it was very high so we
two things happened because of that one
you have a very good move you don't have
an excellent movie because you couldn't
afford it to be at excellent but you
have a very good movie so you can have
less fear in terms of pushing that movie
towards journalists towards other people
there's a definitely recommend score
that's very high so again less fear in
terms of pushing it towards journalism
journalists and uh and trying to get
reviews and whatever else invariably
people do like the film mostly people
like the film so again if you have all
those components then maybe it may and
people haven't seen this for a little
while kind of too as well then maybe it
makes sense to keep on pushing this
thing right and trying to keep this not
only pushing it because it's original
but and it scores very well
um but pushing it because you also want
a franchise right these are the all the
reasons that you keep on trying to push
it and trying to do this like the
marketing for it right so I guess the
answer question I don't think I'd change
the thing if anything I wish I could
have done more
um you know if anything I wish I could
have uh you know had a publicist assist
in most of the major countries we opened
up in but what happens invariably is
that you your distributor sells a sub
distributor and it's up to them to do
whatever they're going to do right
you know for the next one or the future
uh it's what's becoming very interesting
it's becoming such a digital world so
there are companies
like film Hub and Indie rights and they
have reach that is um that is global now
so maybe we open up on iTunes through
our 20 you know from our company that's
only going to take 20 from us it's not
going to give it to a sub distributor we
open up ourselves and we open up all
over iTunes all over the world all over
Google play All Over YouTube all over
the world next time and we don't have to
take this person that's going to like
take their you know 20 of 20 of whatever
and we hire publicist for the major
markets ourselves and we do it we raise
awareness that way that would have been
a if I could have my if I had the money
and I had like the wherewithal that's
what I would have done and I can tell
you this probably gonna do next time
and sometimes a personal email from a
filmmaker can work just as well I don't
know maybe there is a perception there's
a stigma if you don't have a publicist
but sometimes some of that just goes
into this noise category sometimes but I
tell you this though I mean look it's
about hiring the right publicist because
there are certain publicists that are
very lazy they're like I tried your
movie doesn't start anybody I can't do
anything
well why don't you pick up the phone and
do your job that's my question you know
what I mean like I know you can call you
like if you know you have a good movie
called look I know you watch a lot of
shitty movies I know I've sent you
shitty movies this is a good movie okay
please just watch this please just watch
this I promise you it's good that's what
you can do right that's essentially what
we did like when we did when we went and
got like got reviews and stuff like that
any publicist workers Hall can do that
too right and it's about finding the
right one who gets your movie who
believes in it who's not gonna just like
I don't know what to do with it no go
figure something else go do your job
right that's that you need to find the
right partner and that's about doing
research like I mean look you do
research if I gotta find the best horror
publicist in Germany I don't know who
that person is but I'm gonna find out
you know so you do that that's what I
wish if you could have done that I would
have done that but I'll do that for the
next one because I'm gonna hopefully the
money stays with us more than going to
other people next time because of this
digital Marketplace we live in now
and where did you exactly get these test
numbers from aside from going to
festivals and seeing what we tested the
movie ourselves we did we didn't it
wasn't as uh is as formal as what we
would do at the Nielsen RG and different
companies I've worked for otx research
um we took 20 people at a time watched
had them watch the movie and then did a
focus group on them and we gave them
cards and then we did we did five groups
in total so we had a hundred cards right
so we called the data and we're able to
see little you can't see a lot because
it's only 100 people but you can see
patterns and you can see Trends so we
were able to take that information and
have the confidence that that we did
have to to do everything we did where
did you find these 20 people these
friends of friends friends of friends
friends of friends I mean some of them
maybe a couple of friends and family but
really try to get friends and friends
and and whatever you think whoever you
think the audience is going to play
whoever like the age group you're
thinking in your mind that's what you
try to get try to get a spread someone
knows somebody and get you a 50 year old
or you know whatever I do
um uh you know somebody knows I'm gonna
get you a teenager
um you have to like it's it's as much as
doing a job to organize that screening
as it is anything else and people get
paid a lot of money to do that
professionally so you know that's that's
the whole thing if you do it yourself
you're doing the poor man's version of
it then then try to ask for help from
friends of friends like everyone has
social media you can go on Facebook and
be like hey friends I need some help
we're testing this movie getting some
friends of friends you know I'm gonna
feed you dinner we might give you a
glass of wine I'm not exactly scientific
I know but just enough to they they feel
appreciated and they're gonna hopefully
see something interesting ah so this was
they saw it as a group and they saw it
in person it wasn't a screener yeah
interesting we wanted to get them in a
room and then do a focus group on them
so I know a lot of moderators in the
business so we were able to get like
moderators for each of those five groups
and that gives us more information too
we would tape those conversations and
and doing a moderator gets you different
information than you would get on the
page as well there's something organic
about it a lot of times and people feel
you know free hopefully if it's a good
moderator and they feel you know able to
talk about their feelings and they don't
feel like they have to you know mix the
words or whatever
right and so then did you get a special
screening haul or this was just at
someone's home just just on my house oh
okay great